hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
aggressive phobia okay I've been looking
around and I realized I didn't check in
this from again so I scanned the room
and I found this obviously so their
clock whoa oh my oh wait what did that
do hi hi what'd I do
I did something over on mark side the
best I'm gonna go ahead and say this
guy's me I'm a badass
now what did that do I make it look like
a aureus what did oh whoa hello hi well
now it's love oh you dick it's really
dark in here Thank You statute well war
tardes and now I take this guy and go
over to the other area flute okay
no war terms
yes now we're in business
oh no time for that ain't nobody got
time for that
oh that's lovely
that's remember the Lightning effects
being in any other game oh that's how I
could tell the other brighter and nice
let's explore here first
ooh this is lovely that oh it's a heart
oh okay this is the moment where I
express my love to all my fan girls no
yes no yes yes okay I don't know why
there's a heart there maybe it's not
hard maybe you need to light the rest of
them but it's true no yes no yes okay
office knock on the door please
whump whump whump whump whump whump
knocking ah I need to knock with
something a bit dirtier come here yeah
that's right I know so strange no one's
answering me
it's locked this is not love oho okay
I'll go somewhere else it impossible to
get past this hole says you oh wow Simon
always was an idiot
we need to get out of here we need to
get out of this hole or at least you do
you dumb piece of crap
alright okay Simon just died Simon is
the Luigi tunnel it's locked I might be
able to escape some of the tunnels but
the doors locked and I'm not strong
enough to break it Simon of course the
Simon's the douche of the trio of the
duo I mean is there anything in here
besides some statues
okay got very quiet all of a sudden I
don't know why see what's upstairs
[Music]
I don't know why well seriously whenever
I see whoa I see that I just it's not
good it's not good I just like Oh God
yeah okay everybody shut up shut up Joe
is there something there it's Co hangar
sorry let's go see the real the brave
one because Simon's is a little wimpy
baby go ahead come on
well I mean I'm in the quarters
obviously okay oh hi Alexander okay okay
all right all right all right
[Music]
mmm oh I don't know I don't like I don't
want get away go away oh okay it's
impossible to get passes holders where
it looks like a door out of here
oh okay this looks like another door out
of here
don't worry gonna go back Tommy I don't
like I do not like them I don't I just
have plain and simple it's decide do not
there's nothing about them that I like
and it's alright okay I'm okay
oh this looks lovely could I ever oh oh
oh oh give me Lanta
give me a lantern give me a lint give me
a lighter
oh it's dark I should find the other
drill parts I need two more how do you
know the other parts are broken into two
way oh no like hell
what is this [ __ ] Flender Jesus stop
with the thumping you're freaking
yanking my chain okay here all right
okay I'm something's blocking the door
let me guess a monster why am I even
down here of course me I'm mark and I'm
the brave one I'll get some light please
please let me get some light please can
I please thank you refuge the monster
comes chasing after me seriously that's
like the exact same thumping that was in
slender so freakin dark oh oh my I say
just not gonna give me a frickin Lantern
oh no no good
something down here I can't even get
there oh that's friggin barrel rolling
around I was like oh my god oh man oh
god shut up god I swear the atmosphere
in this one is ten bajillion times more
than anything I've come across hi Zeus
tonight was great I can still feel you
next to me it might not be anything
special but I have made some kind of
health potion I know it sounds crazy but
somehow it helps you heal you you wounds
much faster than the human body can if
you want it it's yours and thank for it
and as I thank for tonight this storage
keeper what oh you stop that right now
you douche omok and you gotta be kidding
me
you can't be freaking kidding me you
gotta be kidding me you got to be
kidding me
oh no no no no no no no open open
[Music]
there's nothing else here besides these
why do I need these I'm gonna get hurt
that machine does that rain I don't know
why did I need those was there nothing
else down here I don't like it I don't
like it okay here we go I found
something okay
that's what's blocking the door aha the
other drill part oh oh God oh I'm like
expecting slender to pop out
the Slenderman just get me out get me
out of here get me out of here get me
out of here
why did I need this film why did I need
the drill I need to somehow get this
drill to Simon I don't know why oh why
by doing down here
poison gland why do I need a poison that
it I'm not doing so well that's probably
why I got the oh let me out oh you got
to be kidding
let me up let me up please please you
just did you just did that's where this
got some stories
that music needs to shut the F up okay
am i out of here is this is this all I
need maybe if I just swap over I'll give
it I'll have the items in my inventory
I'm gonna assume that I I toss it over
to Simon we're just gonna assume oh okay
hey Simon I've got some stuff they might
be useful here catch okay
I talked it over all right keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going just get it get in
there and go okay no reason to go back
no one else ah where am I going
wait what if I why did I need this
poison gland I have no idea all right
thanks mark you're the best you are the
bravest to go down two tunnels it said
tunnels have it
[Music]
okay I just need to calm down here the
funny thing is nothing's happened
absolutely nothing has happened how did
I miss that tuna box
absolutely dick diddly has happened with
his heart his hat for shoes Oh what am I
supposed to use is for office this is
locked no man I got these things but now
what do I do with them I even know I
could have sworn that I was like the
whole objective is escape through the
tunnels with the doors locked I'm not
strong enough to break in so I assume
but I don't know all right all right all
right
so I'm actually all out of time so thank
you guys so much for watching this is
shaping up to be quite quite a
incredible custom story so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more stuff that I've done
check out my highlights down below and
as always see you in the next video
bye-bye